americans are fed up with corporations
pushing woke politics from coca-cola to
major league baseball it seems like
liberal ideology is creeping in
everywhere just this week american
express got called out for telling
employees capitalism is racist
entrepreneur vivek ramaswamy is exposing
how these giant companies mix politics
with business and use it to influence
our lives he has a new book coming out
called woke incorporated and a special
airing this sunday on fox news at 10 pm
eastern and it will also be available on
fox nation that day here's a preview
i think there's now as i said before a
chinese word for wokeness bites will
they understand this game far more
deeply than any of us do and i think
that they are now using
wokism as a geopolitical tool to advance
their own agenda there's nothing like
the threat if we get it wrong here at
home if we aren't focused on the things
that matter the value sets that our
founders left to us that understanding
of our republic then the chinese
communist party will have this space
vivek thanks so much for being here uh
how bad does it have to get before
corporations stop doing this well in
fact it's how bad it's gotten is
actually feeding even worse behavior
going forward because that's what i was
talking about right there they're
effectively doing what allows them to
make the most money at the expense of
american interests they will go to china
they won't see a peep about injustice in
china but they will constantly criticize
alleged social injustice here at home
which has geopolitical consequences that
weaken us compared to china and that's
just the first part of it the real
threat that i talk about in the special
is this is a threat to american
democracy where each of us should have a
say in what constitutes our moral values
rather than a small group of ceos and
investors right vivek we we we were you
were on my show i don't know a couple of
weeks ago and we were talking about how
this is kind of a misdirection that the
the the corporations go woke so you
won't actually pay attention to the
outrageous profits they make the high
interest rate and their um their slogans
like membership has its privileges
as they as they lecture their employees
on privilege they are charging
outrageous high interest rates that's
what they're trying to do is to the dumb
activists hey look over here while we
can still do this so i thought i had an
idea what if
what if we asked american express to put
their money where their mouth is and
cancel credit card debt 800 billion
dollars right if you really believe in
social justice and equity
why don't you do the right thing and
can't it's it's like five i think it's
five million americans or have an app
it's an average of five grand a debt
why don't they do that
so greg you just nailed it these
companies blow woke smoke to cover up
the topics they'd rather not be talking
about that is what this whole charade is
about funny thing about american express
you nailed it is their black card
doesn't apply to black people it
actually applies to people who spend
millions of dollars per year so there's
the first commandment of what capitalism
which is the more ruthless your business
is the more woke you have to act that is
the game that is the charade and i think
the first step in solving the problem is
actually just putting some sunlight on
the issue putting sunlight on the issue
exposes the hypocrisy and doesn't let
them have it both ways i have to correct
you though because it's not smoke
because smoke raises the earth's
temperature it is like harmless vapor
that they're blowing
well climate change is indeed one of
their favorite topics especially the
racially disparate impact of climate
change which is a great way of changing
the topic from economic injustice which
corporations love to do environment it's
environmental racism so vivek uh greg
hit on something so my big question is
do they actually believe in this stuff
um they promised 50 billion dollars all
these companies to black causes they've
only given out 250 million dollars it
was an article in the wall street
journal in fortune so
is this all about virtue signaling and
not actually putting the money where the
mouth is i think it is mostly about
virtue signaling and here's the problem
with virtue signaling is at some point
signaling your virtue becomes more
important than being virtuous itself and
i think you take a company like unilever
which talks about the immutable laws of
intersectionality according to its ceo
allen job yet does not pay its kenyan
tea pickers who are ultimately raped in
some cases killed and maimed by their
own colleagues who are now seeking
justice from unilever and unilever is
denying that to them that's one of the
things i talk about in the book that's
one of the rules of how this game is
actually played but at the end of the
day i think it's even worse when some of
them are authentic about it jack dorsey
isn't doing it just to make an extra
buck he has enough bucks some of these
guys who are doing it authentically are
even
worse they're using their market power
to exercise undue influence in the
marketplace of ideas so it's a little
bit of both
yeah i have i have a question
well i i
picking backing off what a lot of people
said here they're not really doing
anything i hear about a lot of seminars
right which is as far as i understand it
you sit there you eat sandwiches if they
really cared what do these people go out
and volunteer and why aren't more people
calling them out on that i think a lot
of it is
they make people afraid how do people
get beyond this fear of saying uh you're
not really woke you're just sitting
there eating sandwiches and listening to
somebody say crazy stuff
it is this new culture of fear in every
direction but in corporate america the
way it works is you'd rather be talking
about woke values or applauding
diversity and inclusion or applauding
equity or musing about the racially
desperate impact of climate change then
you would be talking about occupy wall
street which is actually when i think
all of this began after the 08 financial
crisis wall street was scared of occupy
wall street but getting on these woke
values that was actually really easy so
that's when all of this began in the
last decade is really the after effect
of what's happened since then just
awesome hi vivek uh they saved the
wokist for last i was particularly taken
by what we saw in the little preview
where you said that wokism is being used
as a geopolitical tool could you expound
on that a little bit more
sure so effectively the way it works in
china is they will build a great chinese
wall that prevents you from entering the
chinese market if you criticize the ccp
but they will roll out the red carpet if
you criticize the united states so if
you take disney they said they couldn't
film in the state of georgia if georgia
passes a new anti-abortion statute but
they film mulan in the xinjiang province
of china which is ground zero of the
uyghur human rights crisis and they
actually praise the ccp and what that
allows china to do is when they get
pressed on their human rights issues by
the u.n by the eu the thing that xi
jinping now says is that black lives
matter shows that the united states is
no better because the international
arbiters of moral justice the supposedly
neutral corporations are praising china
while they're criticizing the united
states so i think that's actually
dangerous geopolitically it undermines
our greatest asset which isn't our
nuclear arsenal it is our moral standing
on the global stage that's what's at
stake here
exceptionalism i think vivek thank you
so much vivek
great to see you can't wait to watch the
show read the book woke incorporated is
this sunday night at 10 pm eastern thank
you so much vivek
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else